President Obama actually withheld more
information spent spent 36 odd something
million dollars under the Freedom of
Information Act to withhold information
from journalists this is not does not
matter we are not going to Obama to
compare Obama's ashes I don't know okay
time for the latest installment of
change my mind unedited conversations
with real people about controversial
topics as per usual comment the topics
you'd most like to see for future
installments below this week we made a
special trip to Washington DC and parked
outside of the White House itself to
deal with one of the most pervasive
myths in the left social nomenclature
today I'm not saying that Donald Trump
is a fascist humanity is facing an
emergency a fascist regime has seized
the reins of power and the most powerful
actually the sole superpower in the
world there's no word for this Ashley
it's fascism I mean I think that Donald
Trump himself is the dangerous
neo-fascist in the mail a flirtation
with fascism in this country now this
government's a hand-in-hand with another
passage troma
i disagree do you feel free to comment
and substantiate your argument below but
we decided to put all this to the test
unfortunately turns out most people
visiting the White House actually really
like President Donald Trump
so much so in fact it was hard to get a
whole lot of people willing to sit and
have a civil disagreement at all though
we did get quite a few as per the usual
drive-by yelling
[Music]
I you the liar
but we finally sat down with a couple of
people to have hopefully a productive
discussion about Donald Trump fascism
and accusations therein as always before
you engage in civil disagreement it's
important to define your words I'm glad
you've asked let's agree to start with a
definite you want to read that from in
us from merriam-webster political
philosophy movement or regime that
exalts nation Wow and often raised above
the individual and stance or
decentralized reading that I would say
no because I don't think he exalts the
nation at all okay well hon it continued
its centralized centralized autocratic
government headed by a dictatorial
leader well I do think she's dictatorial
okay severe economic and social
regimentation no forcible suppression of
option opposition yes okay so there you
go you just made a few assertions there
based on the definition of fascism but
we agree in the definition of fascism
I'm defining it as merriam-webster okay
all right yeah you know so I'm trying to
be as unbiased of the Kenya so where
would you say he's a fascist Donald
Trump I would say that opposition that
the suppression of opposition right the
suppression of opposition okay well
let's see we just had the man's security
clearance removed simply because he has
vocally disagreed with president
ex-general or he was a military man okay
no no actually I think he'd been the CIA
director under Obama okay and he's
threatening to remove other people's
security clearances as well he also says
the press is the enemy of the people
okay okay and then okay so can we can we
great take a couple those now because
just you two okay so a couple of things
for example um probably the most severe
example is he fired Comey right that was
a big one fire James Comey so we're
talking about the investigation I know
we often go to the Russia probe or who
he's granted security clearances to or
removed
let me ask you this is it within his
constitutional authority to do that yes
okay so that wouldn't be an example of
fascism no your problem isn't with
Donald Trump your problems with the
United States law ah then you talk about
he's
he said I want to make sure I have your
quote correct that the press is the
enemy of the people what you said I
think it said oppresses in that
definition yes but you but that was a
quote that you use right he's that
Donald Trump I said the press is the
enemy of yes he says the press is the
enemy of the people
okay you know what that quote actually
comes from no I don't just darlin yeah
Donald Trump didn't say that he talked
about fake news no he's talking about
fake news as a quote that he's used
which was a leftist term I'm sure you
know was invented by liberals which he
then co-opted an enemy are you saying
himself yeah that right now currently
whoever said at first yeah is he not
currently saying that the press is the
enemy of it that exact quote is a quote
attributed to Stalin misinformed yes yes
you are man let's move on I'm
misinformed yes that's seen his tweets
that say the press is the enemy of the
people
no his television is yeah but let's move
on again to theirs rhetoric I think it's
important and there's policy so you've
talked about the press for example and I
think that's important I think freedom
of the press is very important for
example we both agree if someone sought
to nationalize the press that would be a
problem
that'd be a step toward fascism right we
both agree on that yes okay good good so
we have some common ground there what is
Donald Trump done as far as actionable
steps taken towards suppression of the
Free Press well hasn't he tried to not
allow people into the White House into
the press room he's he's trying to
dictate who's allowed to come in and not
come in that's a small amount of
suppression it's not a legal huge shirt
you know yeah he hasn't passed law he
hasn't pulled out the police he sure but
just in saying that and
in so back to the red ride the rhetoric
so not so much policy it sounds to me
you have a problem with the rhetoric
that's correct
because its policies would actually fly
in the face of that because you you were
the one who sat down you believe as a
fascist so if we talk about policy I
mean President Obama actually withheld
more information spent spent thirty six
odd something million dollars under the
Freedom of Information Act to withhold
information from journalists Donald
Trump is not matter we are not going to
Obama to compare Obama it's ashes I
don't know okay but you said with such
authority that Donald Trump is a fascist
if I may just continue along with my
point here Barack Obama used the
Espionage Act not only to spy on but
prosecute more leakers whistleblowers
and journalists than any president in
history the reason I bring this up is
because Donald Trump hasn't done that as
a matter of fact he's been more
transparent he's been more open to the
press than the previous president
I don't think Barack Obama was a fascist
and I don't think Donald Trump is a
fascist you are saying definitively that
Donald Trump was a fascist based on
rhetoric I'm showcasing you his policy
he say this than if he's so transparent
and so open and so actually wanting the
press in why wouldn't why does he say
that
why does he's because the press has an
inherent liberal media bias dishonor oh
excuse me
why how do you prove that what are the
numbers where were the studies that this
this this mainstream media is liberal
and progressive and communist and
whatever you want to say I didn't
support the left that they have this
bias one thing if you could do me a
favor I didn't put any words in your
mouth don't put words in you but you
change the argument used to which we I
thought were talking about Donald Trump
we switched it over to no mama do you
understand the purpose for that though
you're just in the firm oh no Donald
Trump is a fascist no but why are we
talking about me because Obama actively
shot to suppress the past and Donald
Trump doesn't that's how do I know he
hasn't how do I know he has his mouth
that he does not like the press and that
they're lying and that everything that
they say is fake with the exception of
one news program
a lot of what they say yes is fake why
does he also then retweet
unsubstantiated claims for people see
again we're getting back into rhetoric
could you point me to any I have no
other substantive policies I only I the
only information I have is what I can
read and what I can see on television
okay so whatever Donald Trump puts out
as a tweet that is what I know okay what
do you read and what do you what do you
watch as far as television news i watch
fox and i watch MSNBC okay that's good
I'm glad you balanced kind of two sides
I do that's very that's very respectable
and I actually appreciate that I think
it's more valuable than watching CNN
that kind of plays down the middle when
they obviously lean left and what do you
read why do you know CNN obviously we've
looked well if you look look you want to
take Jake Tapper's example do you want
to take a multitude of their reporters
you want to take a multitude people
actually work at CNN who have direct
ties to the Hillary Clinton campaign but
I don't want to get off on the beaten
path here I brought that up because you
definitively said Donald Trump as a
fascist right I'm not mistaken that was
your service well I said that looking at
that definition I think parts of it met
Donald Trump not all of it okay so he
has not made laws or he can't make laws
but he has not done things he's not
pulled up the army or he couldn't or
forces he could make to suppress people
or oppress people he has not done that
here is actually because we don't have
these laws and we've been working I
think under the assumption that some
behaviors they were just they were over
customs they were customary this is the
way people customarily did things or
customarily presidential candidates
showed us their tax returns so no Donald
Trump hasn't broken any laws in not
doing this his tax return he simply just
broke in custody what does any of this
have to do with Donald Trump being a
fascist nothing I think I was getting to
a point of that there are points in that
where I get with that definition that I
think he pulls into fascism but not all
of us so you believe Donald Trump's tax
returns as it relates to him being a
fascist are more relevant than previous
presidents and their suppression of the
press
no I was using as tax returns as an
exist an example that's why I was using
Barack Obama in the stream of the press
so I'm okay with using the tax returns I
disagree that that would make him a
fascist no I didn't say that would no I
understand and I also didn't say that it
would make Barack Obama a fascist I'm
just was pointing out the act of
suppression and prosecution of
journalists which was unprecedent under
President Obama same thing we're talking
about you know you just mentioned that
he can't make this into law well
unfortunately because of executive
orders now in precedent there are a lot
of executive orders that have made law
you know most egregiously would be daca
or title nine that we saw from the
previous administration where as
executive actions are simply meant to
actually guide current laws and how they
are interpreted so he could so a good
example of fascism would be someone who
would sign an executive order that would
actively suppress the press he hasn't
done that an executive order you know
somehow using the Second Amendment or
changing it they're up for a free
citizenry to be an armed populace or
signing an executive order for example
that might silence freedom of speech to
roundabout ways he isn't done any of
those things you know he has actually
rolled back regulations rolled back
taxes rolled back red tape he's been
less invasive into your life so I just
don't see how my life yes and he can
break laws and get away with it that's
unfortunately been the case with you
everyone here is breaking laws if you
were to I'm general Washington DC there
no no I don't live in DC I'm not I'm not
from Washington okay so he can what laws
would you say he's broken gotten away
with of the immigration okay the problem
at the border then when people cross the
border and try to apply for
what are these the people who are saying
that they are being oppressed or
have troubled in their home countries
yes I love a refugees right and so he
says he is saying there are no refugees
these are simply all illegal immigrants
and as they step foot across the border
they are now criminals yes so is he not
breaking is that a large that simply
accustomed United Nations somebody put
out and said you have to take refugees
in is he not breaking laws no he's not a
member that is United States law your
problem would be with existing United
States law if you cross the border so
you can enter this country illegally
it's me I'm not down there or saying you
can't come across no there should be
some yeah no I'm saying I'm personally
not down there saying these people are
allowed to come across but something one
could be just President Trump has his
group of people down there saying
they're not allowed to come up right
okay they're not allowed to cross how is
that fascism I'm saying well he's
breaking laws no he's not he's enforcing
United States immigration law you can't
[ __ ] immigration law versus the
problem of the refugees who were coming
here and saying I would like to apply
for refugee status I would like to prove
that I've been sure and and they just
they're not giving their day at court
they've had I think there was something
report of a woman who was her day that
she was supposed to actually be in court
wasn't on a plane being sent back to
young Venezuela or Guatemala or wherever
and the judge says get her back here can
I ask you a question I want because we
like we just and I appreciate you taking
the time and I appreciate you being
civil um I think we're maybe missing
each other here can you explain to me
someone crosses the let's say Mexican
American border right does so without
any verification just does so in the
heat of the night illegal immigrant what
is the difference between somebody who
does that and somebody who does it and
seeks refugee status what's difference
being an illegal immigrant and an
undocumented refugee who comes here
illegally
I think if there were people who were
sitting at the border trying to walk in
- from what I understood that there were
there sort of government spots where
they could walk in there and say I'm
here as a refugee please allow me in
those places were closed down how do you
make it impossible for them not to obey
the law and then arrest them and say you
disobeyed the law what law is he
disobeying by not allowing illegal
immigrants I tell you I'm not sure if
it's United States law if this is NATO
if this is some bleep it's not that we
we signed treaties with people saying we
are gonna treat refugees now in this
certain way it's not what's not it's not
you said you don't like a lot it's not a
lot so because when you brought up who
protects the refugees who gave us this
that you know a refugee comes in and
says please let me in
III understand for I understand where
you're coming from a place of compassion
right these you know and please don't go
there please don't go there we're trying
to say that to me a fascist is a person
who I'm not coming from compassion I'm
coming from this position an insult I'm
coming I understand that because I'm
compassionate towards these people but
rule of law does matter your problem is
not with not allowing these people to
come in no he's not he's not bringing
why I think that's important again
there's nothing fascist about having
borders I think if we go back to fascism
we're talking about autocratic control
of government or a racial ethno estate
there's nothing fascist about actually
enforcing current immigration law what
you know what they are does anyone know
what they are yes what are they you're
not allowed to come into this country
illegally and you should be deported it
what about the refugees I said I'm not
talking answer your legal are absolutely
I'm in prevented from doing it legally
then what is that that is enforcing
immigration laws that is not do you
believe that - right that anyone who
wants to come here should be able to be
granted citizenship no okay so what's
the problem with vetting people you are
trying to twist this around you were not
addressing the refugees you're not
addressing the fact that people are
coming here from Venezuela or Guatemala
whatever South American countries
they're trying to come in sure saying
that I can
stay there yeah we've irrelevant oh you
have such compassion but it is the law
it is irrelevant of the law yes but it's
very compassionate of you to say that
it's too bad well you just know you
don't know what the law is and then I've
informed what the law is and then you
sit Donald Trump is a fascist so I want
to make sure that I understand this you
believe Donald Trump is a fascist
because you didn't force it you've
already so pressured speech
do you believe Donald Trump is a fascist
because enforce immigration you guys can
just twirl stuff around I'm not trying
to turn your life around and say all you
want pretend to be compassionate and
you're not can I say one less one less
thing can we discuss this very hot I
know it's very hot let me let me see if
we can find common ground on this I
doubt it you doubt it I think you might
I think he may be surprised okay I
actually have a real problem with
fascism and that would be the first I
would be locking arms with you against
fascism if for example it was like man
if for example man who probably the most
can I say fight in for American rights
and laws mr. McCain Senator McCain in
the disrespect he showed that man excuse
me okay well you didn't allow me to
speak but that's pretty disrespectful I
would say yourself thank you turns out
respect is a one-way street by the way
before the next interview this is a good
time to let you know to hit the
notification bail because subscriptions
don't mean anything anymore or join my
club a lot of credit calm slash mug up
for the full one-hour Daily Show not
only to get the show every day as
opposed to just the clips along with
this wondrous hand etched hand-painted
mug but most of these changed my mind's
and similar videos get D monetize the
moment they're uploaded to Mudd Club is
the only way to support at $69 per year
for students veterans or active military
try it for a whole week before you join
okay let's talk to this next guy
Alexi yes nice to meet you could you
scoot a little closer so we can get
young sorry I know I know it's hot so
it'll make me remind you about the
scooching all right good
so Alexi yeah I don't know how much you
know you just watched someone else sit
down yeah let me just kind of reassert -
sir I'm getting I think I'm getting
heatstroke after burp is it okay if we
go for it
no might just be throw up later on um
you know this is uh unedited so whatever
we talk about is it's going to be
genuine people will see entirely what
what is discussed not taken out of
context we're not doing the sound bites
we're not pushing for gotchas hopefully
productive discussion rationalizing our
positions you know you've seen a lot in
the media particularly the progressive
left they labeled Donald Trump a fascist
accuse him of fascism I just don't agree
at all if you think I'm wrong you're
welcome to change my mind well what is
what is fascism
what are they labeling a mess yes well I
think it's important to go to the
definition we have it here from Miriam
Webster with if you could read that
they'd appreciate it I know what it is
but could you read that out loud we've
got it the whole political philosophy
movement or Russian regime that exalts
nation and often race above the
individual that stands for a centralized
autocratic government headed by a
dictatorial leader it's a hard word I
get that one Victoria Lynn like
dictatorial yeah yeah don't worry severe
economic and social regimentation and
forcible suppression of opposition okay
or a tendency towards or actual exercise
of strong autocratic or dictatorial yeah
this is the capitalized version kind of
the ISM and that's but yeah so do we
agree on that that's the definition of
fascism from okay so I don't think
Donald Trump is one do matter of fact
yeah sure Thanks yeah so
so something that I feel is key here is
the idea of nationalism okay because you
know it's kind of interesting because we
just had a Senator McCain just passed
away yeah obviously to a degree and a
nationalist somebody who not to a severe
degree but somebody who who feels
strongly that they represent this
country in a in a very noble way and I
think does somebody who believes that
this is a great nation and looks out
yeah intersect primarily yeah okay so we
okay so then we agree on that term right
there you talk about nationalism okay
but there's there's a degree of
nationalism that I think is very is
frankly dangerous okay there's a degree
of nationalism that puts yourself above
other people sure that because I think I
think fascist
I think I really think nationalism is
the is is where people have a problem
and they label it as fascism because I
mean youyou see it from the start make
America great again mm-hmm and now I
personally I really don't know when it
comes to there's so much going on in the
government that I have my personal
opinion fluctuates like by the minute
you don't really know what's going on I
appreciate that means that you're you're
flexible yeah which is not a bad thing
right but I mean Donald Trump is a
racist okay that personally the man
himself what makes you say that
well because he's he's allegedly used
the term he's one term the n-word he's
allegedly using this has come out
although the the whole issue with that
is that woman is is something else
that's a that's an interesting issue
you've never used the n-word no no never
never mean never sung along to Kanye's
college drop out and let one fly out
your window no I have I haven't yeah I
don't really listen to hip-hop is again
oh really
well if you do it's kind of hard to
avoid otherwise you can't do this thing
it is he can't follow the bouncing ball
right that's different but that's a
legend so I don't want it so that's his
conjecture but you just said he's
erasing he he is a racist anyway his
there was there's the way he treats his
employees and his personal businesses
okay so people of Hispanic descent
people who
it it has I don't know I don't have a
fax with me mm-hmm but it has come out
and it is factually correct that he's
treated these people poorly he hims not
he himself his business the way the way
he the way he the way he uses these
people for his business and then kind of
doesn't well can I can address was cuz I
know you're speaking a little bit in
paragraphs and I appreciate it but I'm
gonna yeah you said definitively that
he's a racist but he just said he didn't
treat people badly his business may have
treated people badly who happened to be
Latino right understands for the burden
of proof for you to first off label
Donald Trump of fascist which would
hopefully we'll get into but a racist
the burden of proof is on you to prove
that he personally is a racist and sees
people as inferior because of their race
so we have examples of him personally
appointing people like Ben Carson
personally right working with people
with you know descent you've brought up
that his business has allegedly
mistreated people who are Latino yeah
and you still don't draw the connection
that that's because Donald Trump has
sent orders top-down because of their
race I don't see what is important with
that label you have some substantial
proof otherwise I could just label you a
racist or a rapist with no proof
and I said well there's some evidence
out there somewhere it's you need to
really right now I want to hold your
feet to the fire if you say he's a
racist I really would like for you to
prove to me my Donald Trump is a racist
because I well all my criticism for
example the tariffs right now not a big
fan his rhetoric not a big fan during
the primaries his attacks not a big fan
of him being a racist is not even on my
radar so
so that the okay so I don't have
definitive proof that he's a racist but
it is let's throw that out then move on
to why else you would think he's a fast
so it doesn't one it is well known that
he he treats people poorly okay he does
people right now we're on time I'll
raise just people so he so he treats
people okay
who there was the issue with where he he
was acting in an undignified manner in
at a rally towards it or at a press
conference I think it was towards
somebody with disabilities he was yeah
there's that in there was that incident
we're talking about Donald Trump or Joe
Biden okay yeah Joe Biden did it too
yeah yeah I think his was accidental
yeah well I don't think Trump's was into
accidental okay and then can you insert
because again this bit it's fine him
being a fascist right and you said yes
right how is Donald Trump of fascist
well if the reason why I think he's it I
don't necessarily think he's a fascist
okay exactly but I think his personal
disposition towards people is an
indicator of where his his
I don't think he I don't think it's easy
for anyone to go into a position like
President of the United States
especially somebody like Donald Trump
who and and and and separate themselves
completely their character what you're
talking about
they bring their character into the
office I think so okay yes let me ask
you this so you're saying that you
believe Donald Trump personally treats
people poorly and so you know that
personally he treats me to death yes so
but what about his policies that would
be fascist what would you consider
amongst his policies the actionable
steps he's taken toward fascism
now let's see now this is why I'm not
sure because I don't know I don't
necessarily think his policies okay are
fascist but I think when you can't call
him a fascist by definition truth I
don't think so
I think because fascism is we can go
back to the definition so it's an
autologous autocratic government headed
by a dictatorial leader yes
so it's severe economic and social
regimentation and a forcible suppression
of opposition yes so his I think his
method of opposition the way the way he
the way he puts down people who don't
agree with him yes is he doesn't go
after their political point of view he
goes after the person he does do that he
does that he goes after and this is what
people like about him this is what is
kind of not respectable but it's kind of
like refreshing a little bit innocence
someone who doesn't use political
doublespeak it's okay right but the it's
but the the flipside of that is it's a
completely invalid way of its it's not a
valid way of showing somebody that
they're wrong it's going after thy
person I am NOT going after their policy
I certainly hope that you don't see me
doing that I'd I don't know I don't do
that I don't know everything does and I
do it I do want to make it putting it
back I don't agree with all of his
rhetoric right but again rhetoric
calling the news some naughty names is
very different from active suppression
of opposition's and the lady earlier got
very mad and when I brought this up you
know for a moment to call Donald Trump a
fascist and you would have to call
Barack Obama fascist because okay so
this is important as far as policy right
policy suppression of the media Barack
Obama spent a record 36 something
million dollars withholding information
from journalists under the Freedom of
Information Act President Barack Obama
actually used the Espionage Act not only
to spy on but prosecute more
whistleblowers leakers and outright
journalists than anyone in history there
has been no one who has prosecuted spied
on wiretap
acquired identity there was one that
happened of course with Fox News under
Barack Obama then Barack Obama Donald
Trump hasn't done that Donald Trump has
said some bad things but
Donald Trump has not policy-wise or as
far as action items crossed off the list
done anywhere near what Barack and all I
did to suppress the press and again when
you look at policies you're talking
about a guy president down from and my
this is just my opinion when I see
someone who's deregulated someone who
scaled back taxes someone who hasn't
tried to take guns away but actively I
said I'll protect the Second Amendment
I'll protect the First Amendment freedom
of speech and the freedom of the press
we haven't seen that from anyone on the
left so I would certainly be more
worried about people who stand on a
platform opposing those things policy
wise and someone who says some you know
crappy things granted on Twitter so and
then this ties in with why I think I
don't know if he's a fascist because
I've never spoken to them to the guy
I've never spoken to him before I don't
know like it's hard to know exactly what
he blow that's why I think it's
important look at the policy right which
I appreciate you right but I think and I
don't think I'm alone in thinking that
the the the way our government is
organized is if you look at it from from
from from this point of view right it's
based on the notion of where a
capitalist society right okay so we
we're owners all of us are owners that's
what we do we I mean it goes it goes all
the way back to just basically idea
being owners it's based on the idea of a
citizen the citizenry being free from a
premature manacle government with an
alien but I think that really create
being free to do what being free to
speak being free to practice religion
being free to engage in commerce that's
a portion of it but that's not I want to
make sure that we're really clear the
government is not set up as though
everyone is just an owner that's not why
it exists correct correct I think it
exists so I think it exists to keep that
in check I don't agree with the way this
government is is organized because okay
we so the government's in place to to
keep things like the government now know
yeah yeah so it's it's it's it's put in
place to keep things like it's to keep
to keep people from gaining monopoly on
on any kind of capital they feel they
they have a right to to work to exercise
their labor and to own and to you know
accumulate wealth and to live the
American dream to be you know prosperous
and happy and healthy sure
so deregulation you're talking about I
think is I don't think is a good thing I
think it can lead to fascism I think
it's something that from a very basic
standpoint it's something that limits
people it it it enables people to but
but whose thing you're talking about
something you don't like right I
understand that right but that's not
fascism right as a matter of fact what
you were talking about more regulation
what your tongue would be a centralized
autocratic government headed by a
dictatorial leader severe condemned and
also by the way historically
nationalization of a lot of industries
right so that's not fascism I just think
it's important because words matter you
know we've had people run up and say
yeah Donald Trump's a Nazi dental
Trump's a fascist you may disagree with
a lot of what he's done or said but I
haven't heard you disagree with a ton of
what he's done but that doesn't make
somebody a fascist and I actually see
quite the opposite now you say
deregulation you see for example
supporting freedom of speech or maybe
the Second Amendment maybe you don't see
those necessarily as good things but it
is the exact opposite of what a fascist
would do the first step of fascist take
is not let more people arm themselves
the first of the fascist take is not
let's ensure that there's more freedom
of speech on college campuses and
businesses have the right to speak
freely that's not what a fascist does
let me because we do have to get going
here yeah let me kind of I hope we kind
of leave us with some common ground this
is I am concerned about fascism I didn't
support Donald Trump in the primaries I
didn't like his rhetoric I would agree
with you on the media and libel laws I
thought ooh this is a real problem
especially if somebody works in media
now thankfully he hasn't enacted in any
of the even really suggest policies he
just talked about how media shouldn't
give the libel folks but I would
absolutely be concerned and stand with
you arm and arm in opposing fascism if I
saw Donald Trump for example like
nationalize the media right that'd be a
problem
nationalize industry like like like
health care like energy banks if I saw
him actively trying to suppress the
press or freedom of speech thereof if I
saw him actively trying to disarm a
populace if you added all that up
I would be very concerned about fascism
what would you as well
I would and I just want to say one last
thing I just want to make sure that
because if you do you can't Bert Bernie
or Cortez or the DNC because they
support all those power right and I did
preface this was saying I really this
everything is in my when I look at it
it's a mess I don't really know what
we're going on you can take any angle on
anyone and it's it's valid and then it's
called invalid blah blah I disagree but
okay let you continue so I think I think
his rhetoric is dangerous and I think
his rhetoric is something that is people
people can people can grab onto it right
and they can identify with it okay not
necessarily know why so I touched your
leg I don't worry about it I mean to
harass you not necessarily you know
lawsuit don't worry okay thank you well
necess
don't want necessarily know why they're
latching onto it but it's because it
feels like I agree to that I agree I
understand the point with rhetoric but
right and I think this rhetoric is
ultimately a nationalist rhetoric ok
he's I think he's trying to I mean I was
listening to the radio this morning and
every single Trump rally is USA USA and
I understand this I don't disagree with
pride for our country but I think blind
nationalism is dangerous I can't and is
something that can lead to fascism I
agree malaya nationalism of a pocket but
could we because we do we do it together
we we agree though that the rhetoric
obviously you know to use the term
problematic can be problematic but all
the policies that I just talked about
nationalization of all commerce industry
an active suppression of freedom of
speech in the press would certainly be a
bigger problem than rhetoric right and
we agree on that we I that would be
worse than rhetoric and I'm not saying
his rhetoric is right because what
matters is those policies
yes are proposed by every top member of
the DNC the current Democratic Committee
and that's important to note suppression
of freedom of speech that's
nationalization of a lot of those
industries so the rhetoric bad the
alternative are people who would
actually enact the policies that we've
just both agreed would be worse so Alexi
was it yes Alexi thank you so much we
found some common ground I appreciate it
I want to say one more all right but you
got to keep it brief because all right I
understand I understand it that you're
an intellectual is
that got him into the into office it
wasn't his promise of policy of you know
make America great again was a blanket
statement but it was his rhetoric that
got him into office and I think I don't
think we can we can say he doesn't have
complete autonomous power right now
which i think is indicative of the fact
that his policies are not directly
reflective of his personal opinions that
he conveys through his letters he could
though he could sign executive orders
remember Barack Obama said I have a I
have a pen and I have a phone and he
actually use it to create laws right
which is not what an executive order is
meant to do Donald Trump doesn't do that
to the same degree so he could say
doesn't again which would not not being
negative of fascism and I would disagree
with you I think both his rhetoric and
his policies are people voted for him
and I think you're seeing right now a
rip-roaring economy a potentially 40 or
50 year record unemployment low and
you're seeing people with more money in
their paychecks than ever the policies
are what will win him reelection should
this continue seems like a Lexie's mind
might actually be changed on a couple of
things so hopefully we'll check back in
with him in the future
by this point a lineup had started from
supporters of the show and since you
never get to see these folks on these
change my mind segments we figured we
let their voices of reason be heard for
once Donald Trump is not a fascist
because simply put he hasn't
nationalized industry toys he
nationalized media because he hasn't
confiscated people's gold he hasn't put
people in concentration camps he has
literally deregulated most of the
country hasn't threatened to pull the
FCC license of radios that broadcast
editorials against them when you look at
his policies I don't see anything that
discriminates against people first thing
he'll do is to be mean things that you
actively suppress your speech I mean CNN
so exists so although nobody watches it
barely I was going to say she's been
slashing taxes she slashed tons of
regulation if you were fascists you'd be
seeing a drastic increase of all that
the belief that he's been you know
advocating for the descent of freedom of
speech is absolutely false Donald Trump
is not a fascist because
he's not doing anything to limit the
freedoms that we have to me like we have
a fascist on her hands
he hasn't Carl eyes industries isn't set
price controls no actual evidence to
support he's a facet it's just kind of a
storyline that the liberal media is kind
of pushing the the fascism they took and
seized everything right and that's not
what's going on at all in fact there's
more freedom going on he's literally not
Hitler things like that wow that was
very substantive get the hell out of
here one of these other videos or I
would usually say subscriber hits a
notification bell but YouTube doesn't
even notify you anymore so your only
option now is to sign up for the daily
show the full hour daily show at
laterals Crider com / mug club join mug
club and help us continue the content
we're able to do it were able to do it
relatively inexpensively with with you
know the help of Bangladeshi children
the problem we have with they're good at
web development but not so much with
writing the jokes not an intelligence
factor but it's too much inside baseball
cultural differences so we can up the
game if you join